welcome back to las vegas now southwest
medical is dedicated to keeping our
community healthy this year especially
i spoke with the doctor to find out how
let's talk about how people can
stay healthy this year especially when
they're being reluctant to
their routine care because of public 19.
really
making sure you're staying up on your
health care not delaying health care
is really really important uh and even
if you're hesitant to come in
doctor's offices in all of our clinics
are really setting up ways that remotely
you can connect with your
uh physician your provider and make sure
that
you're keeping uh your healthcare
priority
definitely and i know that you guys are
keeping it safe when people do want to
come
in so tell us how you're doing that so
now we're screening everybody who comes
in
asking about signs or symptoms of
infection doing temperature checks
calling them even the night before to
make sure that there are no health
issues so they don't bring it in expose
our staff or expose our patients
in there we're limiting the amount of
people that can come into the
into the clinic so that we're able to
keep appropriate social distancing
uh in the clinics we have everybody
wearing their masks covering both their
mouth
and nose uh to reduce
uh the spread and studies show that when
everybody's wearing their masks
appropriately and if they're appropriate
masks that really does reduce the risk
of
spread within the community
and then also now that the vaccine is
coming out we're making that available
to
all of our providers and all of our work
staff so they can be vaccinated both to
protect themselves and protect the
patients that are coming in
great and also you guys provide health
screenings for people who
are just trying to be preventative at
this point right i'm going into this new
year people should be
knowing what their cholesterol is they
should be working with their doctor on
their cardiovascular risks and how to
reduce that
we always think about weight loss at the
beginning of the year but really knowing
what your body mass index is and is that
putting your health that
at increased risk if it is working with
your doctor and his team
to uh bring it down colorectal uh cancer
screening
is a huge one it's uh an unfortunate uh
uh still high killer in our uh
in the united states and it's something
that so many times we can prevent by
doing the appropriate uh screening
and then of course women they need uh at
appropriate ages
getting their mammograms routinely doing
cervical cancer
screening and even bone density
screening
for osteoporosis such a great reminder
and of course medicare advantage
patients they have a little extra income
in
and we'll be doing breathing tests we do
testing for peripheral vascular disease
neuropathy bone density screening and if
you unfortunately
you know some screenings do come in
abnormal so what
what should patients do when that
happens so i
obviously if screens are abnormal we
need to get them in with the doctor come
up with a treatment plan now is not the
time to delay a diagnosis
we want to thank southwest medical for
being our community pride partner we'll
be right back